what's that believe nation I started -
did you know series to learn a little
bit more about some of our famous
entrepreneurs our favorite ones to learn
what makes them tick to find a couple of
surprising facts that maybe you haven't
heard before and so today we're going to
learn nine surprising facts about Elon
Musk fact number one he almost went
broke trying to save SpaceX and Tesla we
used up all that they had you know
you've invested 100 million then still
need more money and then there was the
big recession of 2008 and 9 and in the
end I had to invest everything and I was
borrowing money from friends to pay the
rent you were on the edge of actually
and I didn't like her house with a boat
on an island and yeah and just you could
have Stratus it cocktails for the rest
of your life why did you want to take
the risks involved in these businesses
that you've gone into well I have to say
at times I've wondered you know the way
I wondered if I was really the right
right choice but that's actually been a
very difficult journey I have to say
but I think the there are certain
important things that we must do in
order for the future to be good we must
have sustainable energy if we don't have
that the future is going to be terrible
well you're little naive when you
thought I'm just I can easily build
building an electric car and a rocket I
didn't think it would be easy like I
said I thought there probably fail but
you know like creating a company is
almost like having a child so it's sort
of like how do you say your child should
not have food so once you have the
company you have to feed it and nurse it
and take care of it
even if it it ruins you yeah but
supposing there wasn't soft times in
2008 end of 2008 how did you get through
that period of crisis yeah
so we just break for a second okay did
you think I need to pack this in yeah
why not
I don't ever give up I mean I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated fact
number two Steve Jobs was rude to him
Steve Jobs is wasn't is wonderful
Silicon Valley icon is he someone that
you've admired and what have you learned
from Steve's life and work well I
certainly someone I've admired a lot I
did try to talk to him once at a party
and it was super rude to me but I don't
think it was me I think a thing I think
you weren't the question of the first no
but but yeah and I was actually there
with like Larry page's an old friend of
mine Larry since before we go to venture
funding for Google and Larry was the guy
that introduced me to Steve Jobs so I
was like I'm going like Kentucky on his
coat like you know please talk to me but
it reduced by Larry page's all bad so
but I mean he obviously was incredible
guy and made fantastic products that
that you know and I know there was like
a a certain guy had certain magic about
him you know just sort of that was kind
of that was really inspiring so I mean I
think that's that's really great is
there that magic you try and emulate uh
no I I think Steve Jobs is way cooler
than than I am so fact number three he
wants shredded a $1,000,000 uninsured f1
McLaren not really no actually and I
never did although that was one of the
things that was sort of talked at one
point but I never did I've never raised
anyone with McLaren I have several years
I put 11,000 miles on it and I drove it
from LA to San Francisco it was my daily
driver which is the crazy car to have it
stay dry particularly on the 405
um but I understand when you got it yeah
you're driving down to 80 and you
wrecked it no well and you bit let me go
tell ya okay
all right I mean yeah I think the story
that you tell is actually how that
compares
the reality because the reality is
pretty messed up so you wreck the car
you gather the card you're doubling over
with laughter so even what you said why
are you laughing that you just rest this
car and you said nothing you don't know
the funny part
it wasn't insured well risk at the
punchline is correct yeah so I was
actually I was driving up Sand Hill Road
with with Peter Thiel cofounders of
PayPal actually driving to see Michael
Ritz
this is in 2000 and so we're driving up
saying I didn't really know how to drive
the McLaren and Peter says so so what
can this do they like I'm probably
number one on the list of famous last
words I said watch this so I floored it
and did a lane change on San Diego and
so that the McLaren has no traction
control or anything it's just its
massive power to the wheels so 640 brake
horsepower and it only weighs a ton so
it has massive hard way it can break
wheels free at 80 miles an hour to work
through the rear end free and started
spinning and I sort of would say I think
it was sort of I was going straight and
then turned and I remember seeing if the
cars coming towards me while I was going
backwards and then we hit the hit an
embankment consider a 45-degree
embankment on Sand Hill which tossed the
car into the air like a discus and it
kept broke it kept rotating with about
three foot of air air clearance
according to witnesses and then slammed
down on the ground going the original
direction and we blew the suspension out
and now didn't actually wreck recall the
course chassis and the engine were ok
but but all the glass and the wheels and
everything which were shredded and and
there was massive body damage in the
front and rear and yeah
fact number four he has an idea for a
fifth mode of transport the Hyperloop I
know that there are various companies
that are trying to create the Hyperloop
and honestly I think it's a lot easier
than them people think the blueprints
are pretty complicated
well blueprints are always kind of
complicated and I mean yes there's math
but it's really not that hard it still
sounds pretty complicated Elon it's like
a tube with an air hockey table it's
just in a low pressure tube with a pot
in it that runs on on air bearings on
air skis with an air compressor on the
front that's taking the high pressure
air build up on the nose and pumping it
through the air skis it's really it's
where it's not that hard fact number
five he considered buying
intercontinental ballistic missiles from
Russia speaking of crazy things which
went to Russia three times to negotiate
a deal to buy a couple of the largest
ICBMs in the Russian fleet a strange
experience how do you even get into that
negotiation uh well you talk to people
who know people and pretty soon you're
talking to the Russian rocket forces and
you know they says that Russia is quite
quite a capitalist society and and so I
better but it definitely has had some
some weird meetings in places but I
swear they looked like a kind of
sanitarium or something I don't know
it's very odd wiki Nexus team of crazy
yeah seriously this place had padded
walls
why do you added walls it was weird and
yeah and some sort of Russian gallery
was missing a front two started yelling
at me because it's bright what is ready
for the thing it was like supplying it
make it
compatible like this really desire to my
life right and that was the wrong when
you thought I'm gonna build my own
rocket yeah
fact number six reading The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy was a major turning
point in his life basically a sir was
thinking about this when I went as a kid
and trying to find some meaning in life
like what's the meaning of life you know
and I was quite sort of sad about it
actually when I was a teenager and then
I read The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy
which basically said like the grill the
Rope plaid
you know the basically universe is the
answer and you just need to figure out
the question so I think you know that
that if I if I can help kind of figure
out the questions then that I've
considered that to be meaningful maybe
put the name of the first ship that goes
to Mars nothing into the whole sort of
the ship line or whatever necessarily
the first trip that goes to Mars like my
current grade that is a hard goal from
the photography galaxy I think I
probably will name the first ship that
goes to Mars particle and I like the
fact that is that is driven by infinite
improbability
I think our ship is also extremely
improbable so I like the infinite
improbability drive fact number seven he
taught himself computer programming at a
young age and told his first program
blastaar for five hundred dollars I was
I went into a store in South Africa and
saw a Commodore vic-20 and it's a I was
nine years old I don't know samarasimha
at that time and I was like no you know
the most awesome thing I'd ever seen and
you could like make this write computer
programs and make games and I play dog
that you know Atari and other things
other games consoles born I was like
maybe six or seven
um the idea of being able to like create
games that's always really excited I
told myself how to program computers
when I was a kid and what my first
computer when I was 10 and sold my first
commercial program when I was 12 fact
number 8
he believes that we're possibly living
in a simulation that the strongest
argument for the for us being in a
simulation probably being a simulation I
think it's the following that that 40 40
40 years ago we had pong like two
rectangles and a dot that was what games
were now 40 years later we have
photorealistic 3d simulations with
millions of people playing
simultaneously and it's getting better
every year and soon we'll have you know
virtual reality of augmented reality if
you assume any rate of improvement at
all then the games will become
indistinguishable from reality just
instinctive even if that rate of
advancement drops by a thousand from
what it is right now then you just say
okay we'll let's mention it's at ten
thousand years in the future which is
nothing in the evolutionary scale so so
given that we're clearly on a trajectory
to have games that are indistinguishable
from reality and those games could be
played on any set-top box or on a PC or
whatever and they would probably be you
know billions of such you know computers
to set-top boxes it would seem to follow
that the odds that we're in face reality
is one in billions so how many what's
wrong with that auction is the answer
yes the argument is probably it's like
is there if there a flaw in that meat so
much--but someone I'm not sure what
about the error all right no no the
argument makes sense so the assumption
then is that somebody beat us to it and
this is a game no no there's a 1 in
billions chance that whistles based
reality oh ok what do you think well I
think it's 1 in billions okay
and this that seems to be like clearly
what the you know what what is what
suggests and actually I mean arguably we
should hope that that's true because
otherwise if if civilization stops
advancing then that may be due to some
calamitous event that erase the
civilization so maybe we should be
hopeful that this is a simulation
because otherwise they could reboot it
well otherwise eat either we're going to
create simulations that are interesting
of indistinct or from reality or
civilization will cease to exist those
are the two options in fact number nine
he once made a guest appearance on the
Big Bang Theory there you go you got to
be kidding me
all right you're a long Musk I am what
are you doing here I'm washing dishes
well I was on the turkey line but I got
to murder for being too generous with
the gravy
oh man what an honor to meet you I I'm
such a fan of Tesla and SpaceX all your
companies of Howard Wolowitz Caltech
nice to meet you hard it feels great to
come down here and help the less
fortunate not oh nothing better than
helping people which is something I
realized when I was viewing earth from
the deck of the International Space
Station where I spent two months as a
payload specialist that job I was
qualified for because I'm an mit-trained
engineer and I thought I labeled the
gravy optic sorry it's your you constant
I really want you to adopt me well
you're here on Thanksgiving so you're
probably a good person huh I made my
wife come down to you think you might
ever get back out to space if that's a
job offer cuz I really want to go to
Mars assuming I can bring my wife she
hardly takes up any room she's basically
carry on well we're not quite there yet
but we're always looking for engineers
Sony give me my email we can stay in
touch thank you
oh look someone hardly touched their
pumpkin pie want to share it with me
a partially eaten piece of pumpkin pie
from a homeless shelter with Elon Musk
you bet I do so thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'm
super curious to figure out which
surprise in fact was most interesting
for you most surprising for you leave it
down in the comments below I'm going to
check it out also what do you think in a
series this is one of our series that's
on the bubble we've done tony robbins
we've done bill gates with done Kanye
West and this is Elon Musk and we're not
sure if we're going to continue this
series or not so I'd love to know what
did you like about it
do you like it how can we make it better
share your thoughts down below
maybe the series will continue or maybe
replace it with something better let me
know thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whenever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
see